[Music]
oh
he's dead oh he's dead oh my gosh
his eyes thanos rip that freaking stone
out of that head
welcome back to new rock stars one
division is
trolling us apparently i'm randall park
jessica's darcy lewis
we're staring at tv screens for clues
eating chips just like they are
jimmy's dry erase board questions are
literally new rockstars video thumbnails
wtf wanda the
that sounded like the intro to one
division
well welcome to new rockstars this is
inside marvel our one division after
show i'm eric voss here with jessica
clemons
hello hello i haven't gone to sleep
since watching the episode i drank two
red bulls and now i'm on a cold brew
baby and let me tell you
i think i woke up my roommate twice i
screamed twice in this episode
so like oh my god and i love horror but
this is straight
just like terrifying like it's hard
emotionally
and it's hard scary emotionally it
drains me
like it already has i'm gonna cry at the
last episode i said it once i'll say it
again i'm gonna cry
this was truly an empathetic experience
i felt like i was watching us on screen
watching
going through the same process these
past three weeks that you and i have
gone through
making out research boards and by the
way can we give a shout out to research
boards
they're in every movie they make no
sense use a google doc i don't
understand why people are printing stuff
out
and spending so much paper in ink to do
their research that's not
how anyone darcy lewis did make up she
did say like
oh i bet you guys use those like pods
which are horrible for the
environment so i'm sure sword does not
care about what they're
doing they don't well this is our after
show we're gonna explain your biggest
wtfs uh like this show's mcu timeline
relative to end game
learned a lot from this episode of that
creepy ass
corpse vision shot why the nature of
west view's radiation is so
important and really at the top of our
list
jimmy wu's research wall and what his
focus of his research really is
specifically this missing person's case
that brought him to west view
to begin with who is that missing person
we're going to talk about our theories
there
now tomorrow is going to be my in-depth
shot by shot breakdown of all the easter
eggs you missed
in the episode that'll be saturday and
yes if you
are watching us on youtube right now i
am wearing our new latest obsession
shirt an unusual couple it's got secret
augmented reality easter eggs
you can get it at newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you get this shirt
you will get the opportunity to write in
a custom shout out that will appear at
the bottom of these inside marvel
episodes
uh once like ooh who is this uh j van de
castille
just thank you for existing heart emoji
love from belgium
gerbin uh jvan j van
thank you that's thank you for existing
uh as we saw in one division this
episode
existence is not guaranteed and it looks
like uh rita yerby says
maybe magneto will be the beekeeper and
say wanda i am your father
i hope so that would be really fun if
that's how he appears
uh we'll see and i mentioned if you're
watching this on youtube the reason i
say that is because right now we
are simulcasting this live on stereo
uh this is an amazing app you can get it
for free follow us
at stereo.com new rockstars right now we
have
looks like a couple hundred people who
are following us no
3d any killer row x undisputed one
geektown11 uh campster12 i think we took
one of your questions earlier
if you are listening uh to us on stereo
now as i said stick around for a bonus
segment at the end of the show which
we're going to react in real time the
voicemails that you guys send us i see
we have quite a few right now keep
sending us those voicemails we will get
to as many
as we can now if you are watching this
on youtube or
podcasts uh and you missed that stereo
live broadcast you can definitely catch
us next week
8 a.m pacific stereo dot com slash new
rockstars
all right jessica what happened this
episode oh my god
i've been waiting for this moment um
okay and again you guys know how i'm bad
every time this episode drops when i
give you guys a recap i do it in a
different way this time is bullet notes
so let's get into it
all right so after the recap of the last
episode we open up to a re-particlizing
whatever you wanna the dust coming back
monica rambo in a very chaotic hospital
she's looking for her mother who has
been confirmed
died of cancer when she blipped and it's
really sad and it's it are you laughing
i i um it is said i'm just
i'm laughing because that moment in end
game was depicted as such a nice
pleasant moment of like oh birds
reappear
clinton barton's wife calls him but
really realistically yeah they're in the
middle of a hospital there would be
chaos this is an episode that philip and
i did a big question this is not
necessarily a good thing
suddenly a hospital is at mexico same
with like i after i saw that i was like
oh my god disneyland must have been
insane
like all these crazy parts must have
been horrifying to be at
so during the blip monica was like i was
asleep for like 20 minutes when it was
actually like three years ago her mom
died so now we go to sword headquarters
where the acting director tyler
hayward's there and he expresses his
like sorrows and how sad he is that
monica doesn't have the job that he has
she's like hey it's cool we're both
doing our job i'm chill about it
get over it so then it's revealed that
the fbi wants to use some
instruments from sword to find this
missing person so they
send monica down to west view to go
figure out if it's worth having
and that's when it's revealed that west
view is crazy there's people that have
selective amnesia i love that she used
that term because people within like a
certain radius
don't don't believe the world that place
exists and it definitely does exist
or does it or it does it does it that's
insane but yeah and so i love that scene
and so
monica sends a drone in and within like
35 feet that drone disappears in the
energy field and like any normal sane
person does they put their hand
in it and get sucked in immediately so
monica immediately disappears
and jimmy wu is stunned uh sword enlists
a bunch of scientists in all different
fields to help get monica back
one being darcy lewis who's through a
series of scientists smart
lingo that i cannot reiterate reveals
that you can use an older television to
broadcast what's happening inside the
bubble so now we're watching sword
react through the tv to wanda vision
which
do they see that it's called wandavision
i think they must right they see what we
saw also i hate that it took me so long
to be like westview wv wandavision wv
but this episode really nails it in it
nails it in it's like
a remin reminder so source starts
piecing together the civilians of west
view are in the show
connecting their licenses to steals from
the various programs that we saw that
were episode one two and three
proving they're normal citizens
controlled by someone though we don't
get ralph on the list
and we don't see dottie yeah we don't
see daddy yeah we don't see dottie yeah
it means they might not have gotten
there that's what i was also saying i
was like jessica
don't dig too deep in this they probably
just didn't show her
but we can't leave any stone unturned we
have to like
throw every rock throw every rock we
have to throw every rock in every glass
house
so we confirm and see darcy lewis is the
sword agent with the book taking notes
from the first episode
we see the beat who the beekeeper is he
was just a normal man in a hazmat suit
so my theory that it swarm
is out the window you know what i'll
take i think it was always out the
window i'll take the l you don't need to
you don't need to shove the
oh we're gonna be taking a lot of elves
i'm already racing my my elbow so we see
that the beekeeper is just a man in a
hazmat suit we see the
like drones that go in there just turn
into toys which
we haven't seen a toy store filled with
all of the drones from sword which i'm
hoping we see
yeah and uh we see the scene from wu's
end of them trying to contact wanda
through the radio at the planning
committee where dottie cut her hand
and the radio exploded which was really
fun to see darcy and wu recognize the
glitches happening in the episode when
rhonda recognizes monica isn't supposed
to be there from the last episode with
the ultron scene
and they're wondering who's
orchestrating it all well one there's
pieces that we didn't see which was
wanda
had the most menacing terrifying
visuals of someone coming at monica we
didn't see that in the last episode
it's horrifying and it's also just so
sad because it's someone
who's so protective of something they
don't want to lose yet
they know they don't really have and
that chaos
is what's really sad and what's very
angry from her and i completely
understand that
so that being said she shoots she
punches monica through two walls a
wooden fence and across a field then
outside the bubble that we see
when vision walks in and sees wanda we
see wanda
through her eyes she sees vision as the
dead gray
man with a hole in his skull that we saw
in end game or infinity war right now or
infinity war
yes sorry i always say end game for both
and i need to correct myself
thank you i have made like so many jokes
about like that
final shot of uh vision just being like
a lifeless husk
yeah this was terrifying his eyes glazed
over like that uh
there's part of you you are right
possibly that there's just corpse in
here but i don't want to agree with that
but i don't think everyone in west view
is equipped at this point
but vision definitely is a vision might
be and it's really horrifying and it was
great i screamed at it that's one of the
scenes where i screamed i was like oh my
god it's a dead man
it didn't shake her enough to shake her
out of this chaotic fairy tale she just
went back to normal thought of him as
the normal vision she's been seen
and we black out on the beautiful happy
family that is wanna envision holding
tommy and billy on the couch watching tv
but we see the scene where monica is
outside the bubble on the ground
helicopters are flying above her and she
says
it's all wanda wanda's doing it and that
is
the fourth episode and i left out a
little bit a little bit
you'd like well we'll yeah we'll get
into those videos i mean jump over one
uh monica's saying it's all one it
definitely adds some more fuel to this
fire of wanna being the primary villain
of this series
i think it's uh definitely possible but
i think there are some missing pieces
into how she got from where she was at
the end of the end game to where she is
now
so let's talk about it what is our first
uh
big wtf of this episode so wanda the
what the [ __ ]
wtf is jimmy who's missing person who is
it
who is it yeah so let's remind ourselves
of this missing person's case i
cannot stress enough how important this
probably is
um it's the most important clue i think
because it's initially what brought all
the fed's attention to west view to
begin with
um and this is super weird because this
is all taking place what sounds like a
few weeks after
end game missing blip victims are now
returning
uh and missing people being reunited
with loved ones is just something that's
happening at natural pace people are
finding each other
so why is this one missing person's case
such a huge priority
well it turns out it is someone in
federal witness protection
and it must be someone who is extremely
important for jimmy wu to pack up and
leave
uh oakland um so i think that person is
important not just to jimmy wu
but i think that person is also
important to acting sword director
tyler hayward i have some thoughts on
that guy i want i want to hear those
thoughts because
he isn't a good person um i don't think
he's going to be i think he's going to
there's there's something wrong going on
there there's something up he
climbed the ranks of sword real fast uh
he's just this classic like hey we're
old friends right you can trust me but
hey i'm sending you on what i think is
this
bogus whatever case but it sounds sounds
like he just threw monica in there
because he's trying to get rid of her
and he thought that she might get sucked
into this and killed or something um
anyway this missing person
case let's break down the facts so fbi
agent jimmy wu he had a witness in
federal
witness protection that he had decided
to hide in west view new jersey a town
that he believed
did exist and to relocate so a witness
to a town there's a ton of paperwork
there's a ton of like people
double checking hey this is an okay
place a place that exists on the map
it's not like oh yeah sure just call me
when you get to westview
you know like they check out exactly
where you're living
they make sure it's as safe as possible
um
so it sounds like after the blip return
after hulk snapped everyone back
this witness dropped off the map uh
jimmy wu said i thought he
flew the coop but then this is super
weird all of
that witnesses known associates suddenly
claimed to have no
idea who he is or was
uh we're just moving right past that
excuse me uh and then
the town that jimmy located them to west
view i mean there were interstate signs
pointing to it
like new jersey thinks that west view is
a real place
the local pd of east view say ah no town
ain't never existed
i already told you g-man i told the
g-man
you can go take your west view fake news
and [ __ ]
the the jersey accent is impeccable vos
good job that's that's
exactly how people in new jersey okay so
as jimmy and darcy puts together this
lovely research wall with the ids
uh you can look at they name each of the
the people we find out what their real
names are but we never see them find a
new jersey
id for agnes however um
i mean dottie isn't found either as you
said but jimmy indicated that his
witness was male
and uh if he saw that person show up on
screen in any of this wonderful vision
broadcasting he would have been able to
id them from sight so here's my theory
jessica i believe jimmy's missing person
is agnes's
husband ralph um but his name won't be
around for the real world of course
but the moment we see that guy he i
think that's going to be the big name
paul bettany has been referring to
this guy is going to be tied in with the
villainy of this series this is the
person working with agnes
why are why is the show keep referring
to some dude
lurking in the shadows off screen that
seems to be behind
all of this i just broke my pen because
i was like shaking
but i also have okay i agree i agree
i want to say that clear from the first
part i agree but my job is also to poke
holes in everything
not poke holes but find like well what
if
it's this so i did i was like okay what
if the missing person is agnes
and then they were like hey they kept
referring to him as
they uh he they were like he keeps doing
this he's this he's that he's there
and then i also started thinking which
correct me if i'm completely wrong i
have been trying to stay a little bit
out of the news of one division
but we still haven't seen evan peters no
and and that he was never confirmed he
was just rumored
i feel like there could still be
speculation for like someone that we
haven't seen so if we did have this big
bad character that's not
wanda what if that big bad character
somehow like wanda turned
into agnes um this is such a stretch
but i was also like i don't think her
abilities stop at gender
i'm sure she could just be like no
you're gonna be agnes
because agnes is also just a witch like
agnes doesn't see gender also she's
probably like i
powerful first and foremost so i was
like but this i believe you 100
i was just like well what if they did
something like that
i think if it were agnes it wouldn't
have been so casual that he just put up
agnes picture on that dry erase board
right
like or wasn't that was a different
board there's multiple boards there's a
lot of horses let's admit that there's a
lot of boards
um but i think that is someone just
another
unknown person that he doesn't know um i
i think i i really believe in my heart
of hearts that this person is someone we
have not seen yet
and the only other person who keeps
going up that we haven't seen yet is my
husband ralph if you think dramatically
the person you keep setting up episode
one two three
you know like that you reveal later this
is ralph and it's a famous person that
we all kind of know
who is like some kind of terrifying
force you know did they not
did they not bring out bro they brought
up herb they brought up norm
they brought up jones right here these
names as they were going they brought up
beverly
yeah yeah but they did not bring up
ralph because we haven't even seen ralph
yeah
this guy's ralph i'm really feeling it
now let's bring up some alternatives of
who this missing person could be
you might think that jimmy's witness is
the guy who learned that amazing magic
trick from that he did at the beginning
of the episode uh
scott lang now the problem with scott
lang yes he has had this like criminal
history
that jimmy wu has been kind of his care
um caretaker
you know his parole officer whatever you
want to call it
but scott lang is a freaking avenger i
don't think he would be in federal
witness protection
um yeah a person who goes into federal
witness protection is
like the guy in goodfellas you know
someone who rats out his friends
uh or someone who is like worried that
the mafia is going to assassinate him
so you know or worry that some other
government uh corruption
someone who uh has to kind of be a
whistleblower
so they have to protect them as best
they can
and change their name change their
identity change all that stuff um so i
don't think scott lang's gonna fit that
bill
but while we're talking about from
ant-man and the wasp there was that
unanswered question of sonny burch's
mystery
client his buyer they never answered
that question of who that was in ant-man
the wasp
that was the person who's trying to um
you know remember sunny birch who's
trying to steal the shrunken pin lab
um and it was for some unknown client
that client could be our ralph we've
speculated that person could be
connected to aim
uh person could be like modoc it could
be the ten rings it could be someone
like that
and uh oh speaking of the ten rings uh
you know
oakland is near uh san francisco where
part of shang chi is gonna be set
is rumored to deal with dark magic that
witness could be associated with the
mandarin
or someone associated with the ten rings
one crazy hot take the episode closes
with jimi hendrix's amazing voodoo child
hendrix was a bay area musician um
my mind almost for a second went to
brother voodoo jericho drum
a brother to daniel drumm both of them
sorcerers
daniel drumm was that predecessor
sorcerer who oversaw the new york
sanctum sanctorum
whom whom kaiselius killed and dr
strange
and doctor change is like i guess it's
on me now to do this and we know this
movie is going to tie
or we know one division is going to tie
into doctor strange and multiverse of
madness there could be
a connection there i don't know brother
voodoo is kind of a weird
also because i like how you were like
jimi hendrix is the bay art
would they consider him the bay area
artist this is coming from someone
that's from washington state where he's
from so i
will say i'm obsessed with west coast we
could say west coast
he was just famously monterey pop
festival where he lit the
guitar on fire you know like yeah i'm
like okay
it's totally fine i'm just i'm giving
you as many things hey
the dry erase board out of you guys got
this mentioned scrolls
jimmy wu wrote down scrolls which is
insane
because it means he knows what scrolls
are that
is uh a big deal but the fact that he
would mention
as like a potential bad guy who's behind
all this means that he's not necessarily
working with them this does complicate
what we thought we knew about this
girl's relationship with fury and with
sword
or maybe there's multiple groups of sor
of skrulls that you know
the feds are keeping their eye on but
again jessica
think about it a witness to a crime uh a
person who takes a federal plea deal
whose associates suddenly claim to have
no knowledge of him
i get the feeling this is the kind of
kaiser soze usual suspects dude
a devil who tricked the world into
believing he didn't exist i mean who
does that sound like to you
i don't know this is the part where i
was like
because i was like it's the fbi so the
missing person can't be that
it can't be a superhero it can't be a
villain or like too big of one it has to
be someone that's very moderate
i see where you're coming from with
ant-man and wasp i think that's a
logical answer but it also has to be
someone
that's gonna also be in the future it
can't just be like
they couldn't he can't be the missing
person and never be talked of again
i was like stumped on it because i was
like who else would it be that's going
to be featured in the future
that the fbi stop it stop it
it's not it can't be it can't be it's
the fbi it's jimmy wu
so it can't be like someone too big not
not cheap
supernatural person who was able to
escape from these things he was always
able to slip away
on this earth jessica and the devil is
the one who gets
away from these he could be
he could be if you talk to some mafia so
say new jersey i bet they'll say some
devils
they're gonna be like hey this is the
devil right here unless he okay so let's
say if it was mephisto
and it is the devil and let's go off the
theory then
because it's the only door you could
really go through is the fact of just
like he's
losing power because we did bring that
up in one episode we were like i think
he's just weak
and that's why he can't do too much with
wanda he's just doing the bare minimum
because he needs all those powers he
needs to reabsorb the kids um
that were someone else's body too it's a
lot but like
i think he is weak so maybe that is
potentially it could be mafesto through
that reasoning
of like he's in the witness protection i
don't maybe they're also like
exaggerating maybe it's not witness
protection maybe it's just like we just
need to keep an eye on this guy
yeah i i just think like it's an odd
choice to write in there that this guy
would be in federal witness protection
it tells us there's a story there
he tells us that this dude was able he
was also
involved with some criminal conspiracy
but was able to get out of it by ratting
out and letting other people
uh take the blame for it and take the
fall for it that tells us something
about
not necessarily this guy's character
because you know obviously in
prosecution this country we need people
to come clean
and rat out their friends when they're
doing something bad um
but it also means that this guy's got
dirt on his hands this guy's got blood
on his hands potentially
and there is a story uh where he was
relocated but he was crafty enough
to trick the fbi into bringing him
someplace that he could suddenly wipe
off the map
like this guy's got some magic to him so
do you think it was
planned the what not plan the west view
part but like
it it has to be coincidence it ha right
it has to be it can i don't think it has
to be a coincidence i think if you're
writing this episode and if all it is
is just wanda and vision and they're in
this town
and they've done it why as the writer of
this show would you write in this weird
thing
of federal witness protection why would
that be the thing that begins this
mystery why would that be what draws
jimmy wu and monica rambo and sword's
attention there
i get that i get that completely i was
like because it's like truly
a piece of like disney wouldn't write
something that clumsy i'm just like yeah
we're not going to get back to it
we're not going to get back i mean it's
all you would have to say is like some
local sheriff called sword saying
hey uh there's this town here that
doesn't exist
and it just gets kicked up the you know
there's easier ways to do it there's
more direct ways
jimmy will have some other mission and
if it is mafesto he can somehow
underline like be pulling the strings on
all of this
orchestrating it all yeah you know me
i'm gonna find ways to bring it back to
mephisto we have to do what the devil no
matter what because
the devil could also be wanda let's talk
was real talk absolutely absolutely i
mean i think at the end of the day she
is looking more and more of the active
villain of the show
she's being inspired though someone and
i love it so she was not that villain at
the end of end game
someone put that idea in her head she's
hurt she's just hurt
she's completely hurt just hurt people
don't go crazy like that
she was never that evil to begin with
something must have uh
broke her we need to well we gotta move
on um so there's a lot of questions to
talk about uh and we're gonna get to all
of them first we want to thank some
people who helped us make this episode
uh thank you to our friends at honey for
sponsoring this episode we all shop
online and we've seen all that
uh promo code field just hanging there
all sexy taunting us at checkout
fill me tell me oh you don't know
anything you're not one of the special
ones bye-bye
well thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet for those promo
codes and then
applies the best one that it finds to
your cart automatically
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
and when you check out at one of your
favorite sites
the honey button drops down and all you
got to do is click apply coupons in just
a few seconds honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site and if it
finds one
you will watch the prices drop off
screen producer zach recently saved
seven
bucks on a non-stick pan using a honey
coupon
honey has found over 17 million members
over two
billion dollars in savings and if you
don't already have honey
you could straight up be missing out on
free savings it's literally free
and it installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid
and supporting the show get honey for
free at jointhoney.comwanavision that's
showinghoney.comwandovision we also want
to thank our friends at expressvpn we
all know a vpn protects your privacy and
security online
you can also use a vpn to unlock movies
and shows that are only available in
other countries
you can binge doctor who or star trek
discovery on uk netflix
even though those shows aren't available
on the us netflix it's simple
just fire up expressvpn app change your
location to the uk
then refresh netflix and that is it
express vpn hides your ip address and it
lets you control where you want sites to
think you're located
and you can choose from almost 100
different countries that's a lot of
netflix libraries
expressvpn works with any streaming
service hulu bbc iplayer youtube you
name it
there are hundreds of vpns out there but
the reason i use expressvpn
to watch shows is that it is
ridiculously fast there's never any
buffering never any lag and you can
stream in hd no problem
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices your phones media consoles
smart tvs you can watch what you want on
the go or on the big screen wherever you
are
and if you visit my special link right
now expressvpn.com
wandavision you can get an extra three
months of
expressvpn for free support this show
watch what you want and protect yourself
at expressvpn.com wandavision and uh
circling back to our friends listening
on stereo right now
if you're watching the show on youtube
or listening to it as a podcast you
might be screaming at me right now about
how i miss the key detail
of how my theory is totally wrong well
if you were with us on stereo like
looks like 456 of you are you
i will be able to hear you and tell you
that no you're wrong
jessica and i are live on stereo
simulcasting as we record this
stereo is the great app with live social
conversations it's kind of like a
podcast you can interact with
new rockstars has three new weekly shows
on the app
including this live inside marvel every
friday morning
jessica and i are answering your
questions and hearing your theories in a
special bonus segment at the end of this
episode
and that segment won't be available on
youtube it's exclusive to stereo
on mondays we're doing an editor comment
comments our editors john and josh are
going to go through the comments on
our youtube videos and just kind of like
respond to you there
and then on wednesdays philip and i do
new rockstars news where we just recap
and rehash the
the big headlines of the week our first
one was this past wednesday you can
listen to that on our stereo
account and then we'll have a new one
next wednesday and so here's what you do
just download the stereo app follow us
at stereo.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description we're really having a great
time on stereo
uh follow new rockstars get notified
every time we go
live and uh stereo users stay tuned we
are coming at you guys at the end of
this episode
okay jessica what is our next big
question coming out of this episode of
wanda vision i will say first off i
don't know what beef you're starting
with people but i do not want to be
involved in it
when you said that no you're coming in
on this beef i do not you're going to be
a co-owner
bystander co-owner um we're going
a silent partner on my beef i don't like
this uh
number two of wanda the wtf is one
division's timeline
it's after end game that is set before
far from home
yeah the timeline of this one is
surprising now i gotta say jessica this
week i was getting some random tweets
asking like so what if one division set
before far from home
and i remember thinking like why is it
why are people asking this what a weird
question
why does that matter if it's before far
from home here's what i'm thinking now i
think some of you guys
saw a goddamn leak and are like oh so
this can be set right after end game
that's a big deal that it's set before
far from home
if you see leaks don't talk to me i
don't want to see your
leaks at this point i'm just watching
this show week by week i want to react
to this in real time
if you have someone on the inside or if
you go on these spoiler subreddits
uh i don't want to hear uh about the
episode
unless this is coming from the mouth of
the mouse
themselves from disney's youtube channel
from someone who works on the show
or you know or like i don't want to know
but okay whatever um let's talk about
this
the timeline it sounds like they said it
was three weeks after
the blip after the blip ended you know
after hulk snapped
and brought everyone back um and then
that's when
uh monica rambo woke up in the hospital
which by the way i love it they're
saying monica rambo
makes her sound so much more badass hell
yeah that new orleans last name baby you
gotta say the full thing
you gotta say the full thing oh yeah
rambo yeah you just wanna have her tie a
bandana around her head and go
in the jungle and go crazy all of our
asses
without um can we say a little thing
here jessica
that dude in the hospital she ran into
got knocked the hell off his feet is she
super sturdy does she have superpowers
i love how i'm like yeah let's go on the
show where i know every answer because
these are parts i
literally wrote down in my notes and i
was like i don't think so yet i don't
think so yet and also
i hate to bring it up i hate to bring it
up but then the latest teaser that they
brought up
kind of makes me think that she's gonna
show some powers
eventually in this i think that's not
right i think she's got powers
i think she starts talking about this
through the blip
when do you think okay so i think before
i think pre blip i think pre blip those
opening sex of the episode
you heard a flashback with her mom maria
rambo you heard the voice of uh brie
larson there that was carol danvers
saying
calling her lieutenant trouble uh call
back to captain marvel
um i think there's some events some
events between captain marvel and where
we are now in one division
where monica rambo became photon mo
photon was their mother's called sign
she'll either be photon or spectrum
i think she's gonna get it now in wanda
vision because when they made that like
little like maria photon
rambo like that little photo i think
that's gonna be her homage she's gonna
get those powers
somehow being blipped through that world
that energy field
or at sword maybe they i don't think
this is a stretch maybe they
they do it but i think she's gonna get
it and then she's gonna be like
i'm gonna be named photon after my
mother and i think that maybe
if this is her origin story yeah i think
i think it might be
because she needs this she needs to show
up so why did that dude get knocked off
his feet so hard in the hospital i mean
he was rubbing his head she didn't have
a scratch on her
it looked like he blipped in so like
that second okay i'm in an insurance
case for car accidents i guess but that
like blip in moment
where she's running and he just blips in
she just was like running she was like
and also she is strong she's still like
trained by
okay she doesn't look like one but she
is one she
i think she's just strong as hell and
but i think that guy also not gonna take
it anymore
yeah she said where's my mom and started
i'm being told that we have
a um hold on i'm going to play a message
from stereo here do you think monica
will get her powers as a result
of having been in the reality bubble
that wanda created
that was a a message from our stereo
user
yeah that's what jessica was saying that
monica might um
have her powers from that i mean it
would imply that everyone under there
will end up being superpowered if so
that might be a way we get mutants in
this world but
punch through with that red hand smoke
how many are getting like
pushed through at that speed franklin
the beekeeper
a sword agent probably got punched
through is he gonna have super powers
too
i think he just i think he's probably
just became one of the citizens as soon
as she noticed he was like okay now
you're just gonna work at the ice cream
shop
oh you think he's the ice cream guy in
episode three yeah yeah
at the beginning when they showed the
ice cream um yeah or the mailman that
got threatened
by agnes but i think yeah she's like the
only one that we've seen so far that
gets
shoved through and also like it was with
so much power when she was like you're
trespassing and it was like
oh you're trespassing woman what are you
talking about
but like it was with so much power maybe
she put all that power into shoving her
out
and we're in such an unknown bubble
right now that that could have been what
happened
is that she just got powers from getting
shoved through that energy field
i don't know we'll we'll talk about this
more in a second getting back to the
question of the timeline though
uh no no it's me i i brought this up uh
the
um it's taking place about a month or so
after um after the events of the battle
of
the battle of earth right um but that
means it's before
uh far from home uh end game was set
around october 2023
that's when that big battle happened far
from home it's set summer time meaning
it must be summertime
2024 at the earliest um
so that would mean this is taking place
sometime
november maybe december which it's cold
it's not snowing in nutrients but it
doesn't snow in new jersey usually in
november
um unless you have like really bad snow
certainly so i'm thinking this is around
november 2023 a month after end game
which means that like however this
series is gonna
reframe the mcu the events of far from
home
are uh in reaction to that in response
to that
and we do have a setup of uh
you know nick fury working with
squirrels we thought that was sword
maybe the sword that we see in one
division it does look like their base is
kind of a camp
a cape canaveral kind of thing right it
looks like a spaceport
maybe we're seeing the early stages or
the final stages of them building that
space station
that we see in uh in far from home okay
i see that also you just remind if i see
a scroll in one division
i'm gonna be a little mad like a scroll
like
as as a human like i'm going to be like
well yeah
right i wanted to see a villain i don't
if we see a squirrel i want it to be
not a very big deal and i want to be
very hard to find just so like i don't
want it to have too much plot
implications on what's
really true that's why i was like we did
get a scroll mention
on the dry erase board if that's all it
is awesome great i i don't think we need
more squirrel stuff
i'm down with that i'm down with that
but we did not write this series but i
am down with that
so wtf was with that shot
of our dead corpse that is vision
it was horrifying it just was her react
she
after the ultron after being like you're
trespassing in this world that i want to
stay my life
do not ruin this for me she's slowly
being brought back and that's what the
teaser that we saw
i think we're slowly she's slowly d
whatever you want to call it
getting out of it she's recognizing that
there's a reality outside of this world
that she made up um and she's
for a moment uh she saw vision as his
true nature
i believe that is his true nature i
think he is a corpse in the real world
you think he's the actual
i think he is that corpse and i think
wanda is doing so i think she's trying
to reboot that corpse i think she's
trying to reanimate it
i would love but she doesn't have the
mind stone anymore so she's trying to
use some other kind i mean her powers
are derived from the mind stone
they describe the energy field of west
view as radiation specifically like a
microwave uh
cmbr right and it means that it dates
back to the big bang
which what else dates back to the big
bang uh wong told us the infinity stones
this is infinity stone cosmic radiation
so whether that's from uh
residual effects of the mind stone the
snap one of the snaps
or monik or wanda's powers or even
monica's powers because captain marvel
got her powers from
an infinity stone um i think she is
using that kind of radiation um using
the advice of someone
uh to try to reanimate vision and that
energy field is coming from her and her
powers
but right now at the end of this vision
is dead he is currently dead right now i
think she's going to die
yeah i i get that i feel that so okay
going back to the theory of like the
cmbr
and the the radiation being pulled and
this might be because i stayed up for
like two hours reading
so many articles on cmp i'm being i am
an astrophysicist you guys
anyone listening to this in astrophysics
i'm so sorry i am not
you actually are good at it i don't know
what i'm talking about but
so is she pulling that radiation to that
planet
because they also said um that wu was
like
uh where did i write it down wu said um
the universe created a sitcom with two
avengers
is the universe supposed to be wanda i
think that was jimmy woo
just trying to figure it out like i
don't think i think so too but i think
it's like
what's happening but then i was like how
are they getting so much radiation in
one area
is wanda pulling that down i think she's
beaming it out
i think it's uh the radiation is an
outgrowth of her
uh magic of her red sorcery i think
it's it's basically the mcu is saying
magic
equals radiation it's kind of like what
asgard describes science or magic as
it's a just science we don't understand
yet and
i think that's her magic is going to be
a type of
infinity stone derived radiation or at
least infinity stone activated radiation
because that's a bit easier for people
to understand what is sword
in his space mission and what is
monica's background which we kind of
started yeah
this opening scene as they were walking
through sword dropped so much exposition
that i was like no
hold on hold on what what um so first
off
it does look like that's a cape
canaveral kind of base that's a that's a
huge hanger
monica rambo talked about being an
astronaut in the past
um his whole space command half of them
were blipped
um now half of them are kind of scared
to go back into space
there was something that monica had did
there's some past incident she's like i
assure you i'm fine despite that now
maybe she was referring to the blip
but it sounded like before the blip she
was kind of a troublemaker she was a
lieutenant trouble
she was literally that was her nickname
now monica mentioned that there were
enemies in space but there were also
allies in space to me that's kind of a
implication to the cree versus scroll
war the enemies are the cree
the the potential allies that hayward
kind of rolled his eyes at but i think
monica
is scroll friendly based off of her
experience in captain marvel
i think that that was setting up secret
invasion right there of like
you know squirrels are gonna be on both
sides there's gonna be a lot of humans
people in sword who don't trust scrolls
because whatever they're green they're
shapeshifters why would you trust that
but monica's like no no we can use these
people to help us against the greater
threat the cree
now the craziest thing to me was uh they
talked about
um sword strategic weapon observation
response uh division now she said that
observation response was added
you she's like i what happened to
creation what do you mean creation
were they creating sentient weapons are
they creating mutants are they connected
to weapon x
is a bad person he is starting okay
so i i don't want to jump on this train
of already declaring this man is a bad
guy
but there's a lot of changes that happen
when monica was gone
and a lot of people are gone so it's and
a lot of people haven't come back
and i think he's the reason for all of
this i think he's trying to become an
enemy
not like an enemy enemy but i think he's
like
some not like the example but like
someone that sells weapons to the bad
guy like i think he's trying to use
sword
for his own like fortune and
i think he's also just trying to get rid
of monica now that she came back he was
hoping she wouldn't come back
i agree with you he sent her on this
mission i think he's glad that she's in
the bubble
um i think he's trying not to really
stay in it too much but everyone is like
we need to get her out and he's like
sure i have to go report something
goodbye yeah i think he was grateful
that she uh vanished
yeah also because she didn't become an
acting director so of course he is
i'll even say that he was happy maria
rambo's cancer returned and he might
have been behind that
i'm saying it's not easy to kill people
to assassinate people via cancer
but if radiation is all over the place
in this show maybe
i mean we know that ego used cancer to
kill off uh an inconvenient
uh person an inconvenient woman in his
life they're not afraid of bringing it
back
this guy is bad this guy's bad news he's
a jerk he might be
the kind of corporate villain of this
show also i like that you noted like
he's acting director it's like in case
she comes
back and what do you think of this idea
that her id didn't work the front desk
guy is like it means you don't work here
and then he comes in is this white
knight like i'll take you in honey
that's crazy to hear this is maria
rambo's company so what we saw
in captain marvel that kitchen table
scene that was the origins of sword
uh nick fury might have been involved
with it but i guess he was involved with
shield and she's kind of the
uh the abigail brand character of the
mcu it sounds like this director
i hope she's still alive though i hope
that cancer was just
no one's ever dead and she's alive on an
island somewhere with an eye patch
she's just in space with the scrolls
cause i love that character i don't want
her to be dead and then it's also like
it gives such a good storyline and we'll
see more of her in flashbacks that'll be
great like tony stark's dad
um now not like in captain america where
he was visually there
but i love getting those flashbacks and
it's really warming and it shows that
like she created a very strong
daughter oh i'm about to throw up that's
right
the um the final wtf we're talking about
this idea of this cmbr this radiation
why is it a big deal
um well as we were talking about cmbr
means it comes from the big bang and
that means it's probably tied with the
cosmic radiation of the infinity stones
now it this radiation that is creating
west view
could be wanda it could be radiation is
just what her hex magic
manifests into because it was uh her
powers were activated by the mind stone
in sokovia
or this could be a theory we've talked
about new rockstars a bunch of times
that
one of the snaps that tony stark's snap
at the end of end game that hulk snap to
bring everyone back
that thanos snap when he used the stone
to destroy the stones or his earlier
snap when he killed half of everyone
each time that happened that was a burst
a universal wide burst of cosmic
radiation
we saw that shock wave in rocket's
hologram
depiction what and this is in the
immediate aftermath of end game this is
weeks after end game
are we seeing one example of
radioactive effects on planet earth on
other planets that could have
superpowering effects
is this how mutants could be brought
into the mcu absolutely
absolutely with the mutants being
brought into the mcu i think this is
maybe this is their stepping stone of
like
okay is this how we're gonna bridge it
this is how we're gonna bring them in
now
like because of that blip there's like
this all this radiation
i completely get that i i'm still like
confused on like
it's there's a lot of ways this can take
so it could be like we're bringing in
the mcu it could be that it's just
wanda and her powers and it could be
like combined with methestos and agnes
also i guess potentially it could if
mephisto was
the missing person um he already was
probably sending radiation there
like let's be honest so it could have
been like already
a little bit but then once wanda showed
up maybe attracted her i don't know
there's so much that there's so many
open doors that we can go through with
magic and so it's just like
it could be anything it could be
anyone's game but i do think this is
where they're gonna bring open the door
for the mutants they're like oh
look at all this radiation that's all
around the globe would be a shame if
mutants showed up
um all right so uh let's close out with
another segment of what the devil let's
go
now now this is looking more and more
technological and science based it does
feel a bit silly to be talking about uh
supernatural demonic forces but it still
could be there
hexagons confirmed to be important west
view is contained with a hexagon
jimmy trying to figure out why so are we
oh we made fun of you
look i'm i'm throwing you under the bus
we were
does that feel crazy i mean that was
like it wasn't just us
they i mean imagine if like uh the nerd
community didn't exist
and you're just watching this show and
you're like the hell is he talking about
hexagons you'd have to go back and watch
one two and three and find your own
hexagons
that means yeah and that means it's
important because they're acknowledging
it
it's not just us acknowledging it
they're like people are probably asking
about these dang hexagons
and we gotta acknowledge that [ __ ] so
whether or not the hexagon is connected
to mephisto i'm not saying it is
it's just like clearly what we saw with
those hexagons meant something and it's
because the town
of west view is within a hexagonal grid
um or not a grid just like it's in the
shape of a hexagon and jimmy was like
why
is it why is it an is it equilateral is
a word it's where every
uh segment of the hexagon is an exact
uh exact same as the everything else
since 10th grade
which is almost 10 years so that's uh
weird
and it means something so it could be
wanda's hex magic
uh it could be this was planned to be
this way
uh could be both um now the other detail
i've talked about this
jimmy's missing person i firmly believe
that
whatever is going on in west view
started with this man whoever he is
i think this is the most devil part of
the episode is like
he definitely is spooky he has something
with him there's something about this
man
that we're gonna find out and it's gonna
blow up in our face even even if he's
not a devil he's gonna reveal
like a bunch of information that we
needed he's important yeah yeah
um and whoever it is i think we can
assume is associated with agnes because
she had no id
they identified her face she's obviously
important but they could not identify
her to a real
living human being from new jersey so uh
if she's not a victim like the other
residents of west view
uh it's pretty clear she is helping do
this to wanda now wanda is a villain
she just because she's might be
following orders she's still the
superpowered threat
she's the sentient uh weapon that the
sword is
reacting to but she's got help and i
think agnes i think ralph are the people
helping her watch tyler be like
orchestrating this
watch him be like yeah we started this
in her she he there he's the
it was an experiment that got out of
hand he wanted to show himself
that he was worthy of being the director
of sword he was like i
and i'm gonna be so mad i'm gonna throw
this my full computer gaming desk
over my head because i hate that's how
this dude got in federal witness
protection he made
a deal with tyler hayward tyler hayward
pulled some strings with the heads
got this guy located to this town where
he could lure in
wanda maxim off this uh heartbroken
avenger
and use her to give this guy what he
wants this guy meanwhile tyler hayward
gets a his deal with the devil gets to
move up in the world at sword when he
doesn't deserve that job
classic deal with the devil the wrench
and the gears was monica coming back
he was like damn it yeah damn it yep i
think we just
figured this [ __ ] out just lock it right
now
two episodes later boom well
that is it for this first episode of
inside marvel the one vision after show
we're gonna be back next week to break
down the biggest wtfs from episode four
and we're gonna continue this show if
you're listening on stereo stick around
because right over this we're going to
do an exclusive bonus segment
of stereo questions and theories we're
going to react to them
in real time are the after party for the
after show the after after show
uh if you are watching this later you
can download the stereo app follow
us uh using this free stereo app stereo
dot com slash new rock stars to be part
of the fun
that is where new rockstars is doing
three new weekly live shows so go on
stereo dot com
slash new rockstars to join the
conversation thank you jessica for
joining me
you can follow her at lulu underscore
clements on twitter lula clemens
everywhere else
follow me at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast
uh we're gonna close with our favorite
moment of the episode i'm a chemical
engineer no one cares
[Music]
you